[Music]
Elon Musk is expected to testify in a
federal trial that deals with tweets he
sent in 2018 regarding the possibility
of taking Tesla private Elon Musk
tweeted I'm considering taking Tesla
private at 420 funding secured he later
followed up saying investor support is
confirmed only reason why this is not
certain is that it's contingent on a
shareholder vote Tesla's stock price
closed up about 11 the day that Mr musk
sent those tweets and it later gave back
those gains and fell further
thank you all for uh coming tonight the
deal which would have been valued at
around 72 billion dollars never
materialized the plaintiff has alleged
that Mr musk's tweets were false
material to investors who relied upon
them to make trading decisions and that
this class of investors lost billions of
dollars as a result
attorneys presented opening statements
on January 18th in the case an attorney
for the defendants who include Mr musk
Tesla and members of the board at the
time described the tweets as shorthand
Made In the Heat of the Moment that
didn't differ materially from the
situation at hand even though in some
cases they may have been technically
inaccurate
the plaintiff is seeking damages for
investor losses that musk's tweets
allegedly caused the plaintiff said in a
trial brief as a result of the turmoil
and the prices for Tesla stock options
and bonds caused by musk and Tesla's
statements investors lost billions of
dollars from August 7th 2018 to August
17 2018.
the judge in this case has already ruled
that certain of musk's statements were
untrue that means that the key questions
left for the jury include whether those
statements were material to investors
and whether musk knew that they were
untrue
musk is expected to testify as soon as
January 20th
the witness lists indicate that we may
get to hear from Tesla Executives and
current and former board members about
what was going on inside the company at
this in credibly interesting chaotic
time at Tesla the trial is expected to
run for about three weeks through the
beginning of February before being
turned over to the jury to decide the
verdict
[Music]